and the New York Times reports your body
may not thank you for taking a break
from exercise there are two new studies
from the University of Liverpool and
McMaster University among others and
they monitored active people who
abruptly started sitting more now this
caused their blood sugar levels to rise
insulin sensitivity to decrease and
weight to increase the studies
volunteers returned to an active
lifestyle after two weeks but the
undesirable metabolic changes did not
fully reverse our dr. David agus is here
this morning you might have seen him
dancing in the green room we noticed I
know although I still can't get the
image of Anthony and that massage chair
out of mine just kind of did this age
factor into whether you can bounce back
after you have an exercise break because
I feel like we all have a period like
that where you end up taking a break
because of work or illness or something
no question about it so in older studies
that have shown that college kids who
were done in they would sit and go from
10,000 steps a day to a thousand steps a
day and you saw all these changes happen
in the body insulin insensitivity
metabolic changes and then they started
to go back to exercising within two
three days they were back to where they
were but in this study over the age of
65 they didn't after two weeks most of
them hadn't changed at all they were
still back to that change that happens
with being sedentary so age does matter
so meaning as you get older it's more
important to make sure you exercise
every day or every other day well
everybody should be yes especially as
you get older taking that two-week break
has real ramifications not just for
those two weeks but for many many weeks
afterwards but less than a quarter of us
are getting the exercise we should all
sit down and say this just now there yes
we're not moving it up yeah
how much is what is the right kind of
exercise when we talk about going back
to the gym our bodies were designed to
move so movement is key it changes our
muscles
you know our lymphatics that control our
immune system have no muscle in the
walls which is the rhythmic contraction
of the muscles in your legs when you
walk that make your body work so it's
movement over time five to ten minutes
every hour try to do 10 to 15 minutes a
day where your heart rate gets 50%
higher from where it starts and that's
kind of the minimum but really do it
everyday movement over time is critical
we're not talking necessarily about a
intense exercise here we're talking
about movement yep movement over time I
mean walking makes you live longer as
simple as that
yeah our bodies when somebody upstairs
designed and engineered our bodies it
required movement so our muscles working
actually makes our body work and so
those couple of weeks of being sedentary
when the sugar goes up that changes your
blood vessels raises your risk of heart
disease stroke blood pressure and all
those other things so the key is you
know this is life is a marathon it said
everyday you need to build something
into it so really the take-home is
movement over time the take home is 10
to 15 minutes a day get your heart rate
up and the take home is make yourself
uncomfortable sometimes do things that
you're not used to doing on the stairs
yeah climb the stairs you do yoga I
don't like it but it works I was a mom
my girlfriends are in town from San
Antonio Texas we when worked out
yesterday for 90 minutes and my trainer
Kiera Stokes she says be grateful that
you have the ability to move yes oh so
inspiring to sort of hear that and
reminds you you shouldn't you should do
it every day but again kind of to that
question that I asked Alex was asking
how about the intensity level is it okay
just to just walk with a friend or do
you have to run lift weights resistance
all that stuff I love that as Nora gets
it what about that intensity level
boxing what we know now boxing is good
for preventing parkinson yes intensity
is key and so you know even as you get
older 60s and 70s you do a brief intense
workout there are clear benefits to it
and so our bodies were kind of designed
to move during the day but that
intensity helps both cardiovascular and
brain wise you know sitting they showed
in a UCLA study thins the part of the
brain involved in memory okay so you
want to remember names of people and all
exercise and get out there all right
we'll be doing the show standing the
rescue doing the shaggy understanding